I mean how do you meditate let's talk
about this so what you let go of time
well I'm not really doing anything I
mean the the exercise is really so
simple it's just paying attention to
your present moment experience and it's
an extremely challenging thing to do
it's not the natural state of the brain
um it's an exercise in concentration
um which is why you know athletes and
and other people who who spend a lot of
time needing to focus intensely find it
so useful I mean it's really
um a focus a concentration practice
but all it is really I mean there are
different ways there are different
methods but it really is quite simple at
its core which is just paying close
attention to your present moment
experience and so
um in vipassana which is what I've
mostly been trained in
um you're usually paying attention to
the breath but there's always some focus
of concentration and the focus can even
be just an open awareness just
watching your mind go just what what
comes into your experience and part of
that is the Mind part of it is the
external World
um so you hear a sound you think a
thought you feel a feeling you're
cheek is itching am I gonna scratch it
am I not gonna scratch it just like
sounds like the most boring thing in the
world and what's interesting is
the mo paying close attention to the
most boring thing in the world is
incredibly fascinating
noticing that each breath no two breaths
are the same that time keeps moving that
your thoughts keep appearing
um it's there yeah I mean it's it's a
spiritual practice for notice it's more
and more beautiful things about the
simpler simpler things yeah it's great I
I like to do that I don't meditate I've
tried a few times uh
and I will but I meditate I do meditate
but not I meditate by thinking about a
thing uh-huh and like holding on to that
thing and just like it's not that's not
really I guess technically meditation
but it's keeping a focus on an idea and
then you you walk with it
and you solve the little puzzle of it
yeah especially any kind of programming
or math stuff you're holding stuff in
your head and you and but don't don't
look stuff up don't
uh take notes if you're only allowed to
have your mind and that's you would
really enjoy a Meditation Retreat I mean
you would also not enjoy it it would be
hard because it's all you wouldn't go
nuts it would be hard
but you you would get it what's the
moment is it usually silent or it is not
always silent or actually at least the
one I would recommend you do is a silent
Meditation Retreat five five days five
days
okay we'll talk later but you might be
my next victim I've I've con I have five
days a long time it's a long time don't
you just sit it changes your brain it's
the type of experience that will change
your brain permanently there's been like
two three four hour sessions
I don't have children how does it oh the
children uh leaving them for five days
and not speaking and impossible I've
I've only done one Retreat since I had
kids I'm doing another one
soon but maybe maybe that's what the
thoughts will be coming in my head you
should be should be getting married
whatever let the thoughts be I think
it's always really good at letting
things just be and
focusing on the present moment and you
might come out with some Epiphany about
what you should do next yeah no I I love
the idea obviously uh I love the idea I
love that you know I fast I'm faster for
three days I want to fast for longer
that's also yeah in a different way
perhaps but it brings you makes you more
sensitive to the World Around Your Smile
I'm not exactly sure what the Yeah the
chemistry of that is but obviously
you're
actually it's not obvious because you're
not always that hungry but you're more
time slows down and you feel things you
feel a breeze all this kind of stuff
right it's very interesting